في السودان الاشتباكات تتواصل رغم الهدن
وضع انساني كارثي وتحذيرات دوليه من
الاسواق اما شرطه السودانيه باتت امام حد
اخر سببه التفلت الامني في البلاد اذ نظمت
حملات لمحاربه الجريمه بهدف بسط هيبه
الدوله وسياده حكم القانون الحملات شملت
في يومها الاول مناطق الفتاح العضليين
وسوق الدخينات وسوق الكلاكله اللفه مرورا
بابو ادم والعزوزاب وسوق الشجره بينما
نظمت الحمله في يومها الثاني في شارع
الشهيد ابراهيم شمس الدين ومنطقه السوق
الشعبي بالخرطوم وابو حمامه والمرافق
الحيويه اما حمله اليوم الثالث شملت مناطق
امتداد شارع الرميله مرورا بصك العمله
ومخازن السكر والمنطقه الصناعيه
الحملات حققت اهدافها المطلوبه بمشاركه
القوات المسلحه لتامين الاسواق والمناطق
التجاريه الهامه والمرافق الحيويه
الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس
التنبيهات